saying that you're feeling lonely with
the projects you have coming up
marry me and then you're um teaming up
with army hammer and shotgun wedding
everyone's saying is jennifer trying to
give us a message like are her and alex
gonna evolve
it's so fun people are digging deep
jennifer but it's just kind of a
coincidence
i wasn't really trying to send a message
alex and i are you know
engaged and about to get married at some
point yeah it just
it just happens that way it's a funny
thing
life and art the way they kind of
intersect
j-rod's destination wedding in italy has
been postponed but right now she's busy
promoting her brand new skincare line
jlo beauty set to debut new year's day
yeah
the 51 year old mama's been serving us
looks for decades and
well we'll have whatever she's having we
literally have a product called that
j-lo glow
and the idea of beauty having no
expiration date you know you get to a
certain age and you know people ready to
kind of like
you next bye-bye you know and you're
like hold on
it took us maybe 26
different formulations like i kept
sending it back they were like how about
this the first time i'm like
no and i thought they thought well we'll
revise it once or twice and we'll get
there
26 iterations later i'm like we got it
some of it is genetics with you too
because we see your mama but what do you
think that emmy would say like is your
beauty wisdom
that you've given to her beauty starts
from the inside out
and i always i always tell her that well
we know jlo takes care of herself on the
inside but she admits
even she hits up a fast food drive
through once in a while
after the american music awards i was
like benny hopping at the drive through
benny's just like a double cheeseburger
meal i was just like
lots of ketchup but what she doesn't
want to do again anytime soon
the super bowl halftime show they just
announced the weekend is going perform
at the super bowl any advice for him
stepping on the world's largest
stage since you guys did it good luck
it was it was it was intense pretty
intense for me
and it was it was all worth it in the
end
i'm happy that it's not me this year and
it's the weekend
thank you so much oh we are all still
reliving that moment jennifer well
here's a little more jlo t you know the
new movie she's in marry me with maluma
well jennifer told me that adam levine
drake and john mayer were all
considered for that role that's a little
[Music]
teeth